what does a good opening of a movie have
to have
it's just really simple i want to know
what's going to happen next
and i and i can't tell you how many
times i've seen the first five or 10
minutes of a movie
and i don't want to watch the rest of it
for a couple years i was a programmer at
the sonoma
valley film festival and
was a program director and i watched
films
and you can tell within the first few
minutes i
you re you want to know what's going to
happen next you have to be engaged
you you have to be drawn in it's got to
be something emotional you have to
connect
um and and
you just really have to know what hap
what's going to happen next
you can have like i mean look you can
have like a great opening
and and that can actually if you don't
have that great opening it's not gonna
propel the rest of the film
because the middle of the movie can get
muddled i think middles of films are
tough
but if you blow the opening i mean
there's no point in watching the rest i
can't tell you how many
first 10 minutes of movies i've watched
so
you have to grab the viewer in the first
10 minutes
um and it really comes to do i want to
know
do i want to continue on the story with
this this character
can you think of one that's like the
perfect opening that stands out as a
model that you would
never feel you could live up against see
my taste is so weird i'm a terrible
person to ask that
question of what's what's a great
opening
but i'll say that probably one of my
favorite independent films of all time
is richard linklater's slacker
it's a totally non-traditional narrative
it follows different people's stories
sort of set in a day in austin texas
it's very much a the flavor of that town
at that time
and i love that movie i don't know what
it is i think it's you know
some of the stories are more engaging
than others but just
just i want to live in that world um
so so that's a terrible example
um because it's not a traditional
narrative structure it's a series of
pieces of stories
leading you through slice of life truly
slice of life but
god what are three mistakes that most
filmmakers or screenwriters make
in the first act of a film i well
i would say that the biggest mistake
that i see
that a filmmaker will make in the first
act is uh
sort of a lack of world building to me
um i would say that this probably
applies more to
genre pictures world building is
incredibly important
to set up those rules set up
expectations and defy those expectations
and and if you if you have not
established that
nothing in the you know the rest of the
film is going to work
so in that first act world building
incredibly important
what are you looking for in a story what
i always look for in a story is
take me on a journey and make me feel
something i want to feel moved
i don't have to agree with everything in
the film
but i want to be taken on a journey
where
um i'll feel different out the other
side i think the films that have always
like impressed me the most are the ones
that
have just made me look at life
differently there's a short list of
films that fit that category
i would say that um spike lee's do the
right thing is one for me that i
remember when i saw that film
when i was a kid it blew my mind a chain
might change my perspective of the world
it has an incredible opening scene
um with that that music blaring is like
it's it's that title sequence is so
incredible
um but it also there's a sweetness to
that world
and um it's it's
it's such a it's such an original vision
um i don't know like like i remember
seeing that film and just
feeling different afterwards and and um
i mean that applies to other like more
mainstream movies like a star wars
you know or a lord of the rings but
make me feel something make you know
move me in some way
um and and surprise me
make me want to go on this journey and
then you know
if we're lucky i've i have a changed
perspective
what is the purpose of story wow
that is such a that's such a these are
big questions you're asking
i i i really believe that the purpose of
stories
is for us to experience things we may
never experience in our lifetime
as a way for us to heal
based on our own personal experience so
experiencing a story that may have to do
with the death of a loved one
may help myself deal with the loss
of a loved one in my own life i feel
like there's almost
films when i talk to friends and they'll
say they're going through some
you know trouble you know whether it be
work related or
you know um love life or or whatnot
or something tragic that's happened i
often prescribe a movie
because uh through the experience
of a character in a film we can help
heal a part of ourselves
and that's what i think story is about
to
to impart those lessons in a way that's
safe you know
i've never been to war you know i've
never experienced what it's like to be
um in war i've had relatives my
grandfather fought in world war
ii he was in the navy i had an uncle who
was in vietnam
um and you know having never gone
through that experience i won't know
what that's like
but having experienced films like saving
private ryan
dunkirk some of the great war films
platoon among others you know oliver
stone's platoon
um like i i you know
those visceral war films really put you
in that seat full metal jacket by
stanley kubrick like
so that comes to mind i'm grateful that
i've never
you know had that kind of experience
um but i do think that that um
really the purpose is to for to to teach
us things
and to hopefully teach us something
about ourselves
and a really good movie it's just a very
personal experience that's why i think
people get offended
by bad reviews and by that i mean
as someone who has spent a good chunk of
my career as a critic
what's weird is the reaction of people
when they look at your reviews for
example
no one gets angry at someone who gives a
bad review to a car
in consumer reports or a bad review
of a food from a restaurant right
but when it comes to something like film
if you give a bad review
it's like a personal attack but i i
believe i
like when someone has a completely
different opinion from my own
i feel it's an opportunity for me to
learn something about
that person i don't i i wouldn't say to
someone
who disagrees with me about an opinion
that i have about a film that they're
wrong
i want to hear what their justifications
are for how they came to that conclusion
but i do find it humorous sometimes that
people will be angry
for having a strong opinion about a
movie
um i think that that's a personal choice
and um i i so i find that very strange
do you think that you're able to
withstand um
punches more maybe some people are
sensitive
yeah i do think that me not giving a
is really helpful in the sense that it's
like it's like a
shield that protects me from just not
caring what other
people think i think that that's i think
the longer you think what other people
think that can be
that could be creatively crippling and
so
i try to avoid that at all costs try to
avoid
like giving a what people think i
mean
you know it's it's um
a worthless exercise i like that writing
a prescription for cinema
yeah i mean look i've had friends that
are just like oh you're going through
this
oh you should watch that movie with
george clooney up in the air
you just lost your job that one was good
jerry maguire is probably good too
you know what i mean like life is a
house yeah just
yeah stuff like like it's just like um
yeah i mean you know here's a
prescription for you're going through
this thing
having a problem like an ann landers
column which i don't even know if that
exists anymore
like an advice column but you're
prescribing movies instead of advice
um but yeah i know there's certain
movies like i watch over and over again
that i think kind of helped me i mean i
know for a fact
like it is there is there is such a
thing as movie therapy
um and that's why i think that people
you know that's why i think that this
this medium's not going away it's
certainly going to evolve in terms of
the way we see it
um but uh
take two steel magnolias call me in the
morning yeah exactly
yeah exactly
you